- [Instructor] We're now
going to explore factoring
a type of expression called
a difference of squares
and the reason why it's
called a difference of squares
is 'cause it's expressions
like x squared minus nine.
This is a difference.
We're subtracting between two quantities
that are each squares.
This is literally x squared.
Let me do that in a different color.
This is x squared minus three squared.
It's the difference between two quantities
that have been squared and it turns out
that this is pretty
straightforward to factor.
And to see how it can be factored,
let me pause there for a second
and get a little bit of review
of multiplying binomials.
So put this on the back
burner a little bit.
Before I give you the answer
of how you factor this,
let's do a little bit of an exercise.
Let's multiply x plus a times x minus a
where a is some number.
Now, we can use that,
do that using either the FOIL method
but I like just thinking of this
as a distributive property twice.
We could take x plus a
and distribute it onto
the x and onto the a.
So when we multiply it by x,
we would get x times x is x squared,
a times x is plus ax
and then when we multiply
it by the negative a,
well, it'll become negative a times x
minus a squared.
So these middle two terms cancel out
and you are left with x
squared minus a squared.
You're left with a difference of squares.
x squared minus a squared.
So we have an interesting
result right over here
that x squared minus
a squared is equal to,
is equal to x plus a,
x plus a times x minus a.
And so we can use, and this is for any a.
So we could use this
pattern now to factor this.
Here, what is our a?
Our a is three.
This is x squared minus three squared
or we could say minus our a
squared if we say three is a
and so to factor it, this
is just going to be equal to
x plus our a which is three
times x minus our a which is three.
So x plus three times x minus three.
Now, let's do some examples
to really reinforce this idea
of factoring differences of squares.
So let's say we want to factor,
let me say y squared minus 25
and it has to be a difference of squares.
It doesn't work with a sum of squares.
Well, in this case,
this is going to be y
and you have to confirm,
okay, yeah, 25 is five squared
and y squared is well, y squared.
So this gonna be y plus
something times y minus something
and what is that something?
Well, this right here is five
squared so it's y plus five
times y minus five
and the variable doesn't
have to come first.
We could write 121 minus,
I'll introduce a new
variable, minus b squared.
Well, this is a difference of squares
because 121 is 11 squared.
So this is going to be 11 plus something
times 11 minus something and in this case,
that something is going to be
the thing that was squared.
So 11 plus b times 11 minus b.
So in general, if you see
a difference of squares,
one square being subtracted
from another square
and it could be a numeric perfect square
or it could be a variable that
has been squared that can be,
that you could take the square root of.
Well, then you could say, alright,
well, that's just gonna be the first thing
that squared plus the second
thing that has been squared
times the first thing that was squared
minus the second thing that was squared.
Now, some common mistakes
that I've seen people do
including my son when
they first learned this
is they say, okay, it's easy to recognize
the difference of squares
but then they say, oh,
is this y squared plus 25
times y squared minus 25?
No, the important thing to realize is
is that what is getting squared?
Over here, y is the thing getting squared
and over here it is five
that is getting squared.
Those are the things
that are getting squared
in this difference of squares
and so it's gonna be y plus
five times y minus five.
I encourage you to just try this out.
We have a whole practice
section on Khan Academy
where you can do many many more
of these to become familiar.